this is the state of Lebanon its
institutions are close to collapse and
now they're being robbed of their past
the state-run national news agency's
archives have been stolen but some
officials believe the intended target
was the hardware itself not what was
stored in it it was mainly the server
and the computers and some batteries
because we still have all the hard
copies of the pictures and we're talking
about millions of pictures don't forget
that
yeah we have we have a lot of of
strangers in Lebanon we have a lot of
refugees we have a lot of poor people
that are able to do anything they can do
just to eat and and to to live amid an
economic collapse metal scrap from
manhole covers and power cables are
worth more than the minimum wage people
are desperate
I've been working for 40 years and if I
don't work every day I won't be able to
survive and even then I'm not securing
10 of my needs there's little left of a
nearly bankrupt State Lebanon has had an
unstable past to say the least it's seen
a civil war political crises and
sectarian Strife but many here say
today's reality could not be worse
for many the real crime was committed
against the nation by a political
establishment blamed for decades of
corruption
there's a corrupt Elite running the
country and nothing's improving
employees in the public sector aren't
given enough money to pay for transport
of course you can expect crime
the stolen digitalized archives had
photos dating back decades including the
years of the Civil War there were no
secret or important files but they
helped tell the story of the country and
while the motive is still not clear so
in many ways does their theft Beirut